die golden gate bridge vom niederrhein
in deutschland verblüffende ähnlichkeit
zum original im us-amerikanischen san
francisco autor christoph karasch macht
während der korona pandemie eine
weltreise durch deutschland island und
japan trennen hier nur gut 100 kilometer
und es ist auch nicht weit bis zur
südsee großes fernweh
das war die hauptmotivation ich wollte
gerne wieder reisen und unterwegs sein
aber es ging natürlich eben einfach
nicht im ausland oder schon gar nicht
auf anderen kontinenten und dann bin ich
darüber gestolpert dass es orte gibt die
so heißen wie andere orte kalifornien
und brasilien und amerika russland und
rom all diese orte gibt es wirklich in
deutschland andernach am rhein eine der
ältesten städte deutschlands
die römerstadt im bundesland
rheinland-pfalz ist der ausgangspunkt
für christoph karasch abstecher nach
island
drei wochen lang hat er für sein buch
san francisco liegt am rhein die große
weite welt entdeckt innerhalb der
grenzen deutschlands nach 15 minuten
bootsfahrt erreichte er das ziel den
höchsten kaltwassergeysir der welt da
sie ist isländisch und bedeutet
ausbrechen
da geht es gleich los der rost braune
haufen
das ist heute übrigens auch wieder der
erste ausbruch des tages und da haut's
gleich richtig los weil es sich quasi
auf seinen nacken eingeladen
[Applaus]
und jetzt
ich weiß nicht ob es von 50 meter will
[Musik]
ich war selber auch schon mal auf island
und habe da zwei wochen lang leider nur
regenwetter mitbekommen deswegen ist das
für mich sozusagen wettermäßig das
paradies und ja es ist so ein island
quickie es ist ein kurzes einstimmen in
eine ganz faszinierende natur die darauf
ins land herrscht und die man hier eben
nach dem finden und nach erleben kann
[Musik]
der nächste stopp auf seiner weltreise
ist japan die rheinmetropole düsseldorf
dieses stadtviertel im zentrum trägt den
namen little tokyo düsseldorf beheimatet
sich die drittgrößte japanische gemeinde
europas nach london und paris
hier findet sich fast alles was das
japanische herz begehrt wie buchläden
mit einem rein japanischen sortiment mit
dem christoph karasch jedoch nur wenig
anfangen kann
anders die japanische bäckerei um die
ecke hier gibt es ostasiatische
klassiker die gebäck spezialitäten sind
nicht wie in deutschland cross sondern
weich gebacken und in plastikfolie
eingepackt auch das ist ganz authentisch
japanisch ebenso wie der geschmack
im vergleich zu vielen anderen orten die
ich auf dieser welt reise durch
deutschland besucht habe ist dass hier
die echte große weite welt plötzlich
mitten in deutschland das finde ich ganz
faszinieren viele andere orte spielen ja
eher so mit dem die schere quasi mit den
großen namen
und hier ist es aber wirklich so du
kannst für ein paar stunden einfach
abtauchen in sowas wie einem kleinen
japan ja deswegen passt der name auch
little tokyo total von japan geht es
entlang des rheins mit einem
zwischenstopp in der südsee einem
künstlich geschaffenen badesee bei
xanten zurück in die usa nach san
francisco
die echte routen ist mehr als 15.000
kilometer in deutschland zu das rund 100
[Musik]
das ziel deutschlands längste
hängebrücke 803 meter lang gelegen
zwischen kleve und emmerich nahe der
niederländischen grenze
das original ist mehr als dreimal so
lang doch für christoph karasch ist die
kleine deutsche kopie eine echte
entdeckung
es gibt keine geheimtipps mehr in
deutschland denkt man oft aber wenn man
die perspektive mal ändert und sie ja
zum beispiel versucht eine weltreise im
eigenen land zu machen dann sieht man
neue orte von denen man vorher noch nie
gehört hat ich wusste nicht dass so eine
brücke in deutschland existiert in
deutschland ein land das weit mehr
abwechslung bietet als man glaubt